[Music]
if you could witness time from the big
bang to the last star going out what
moments would stay with you the most
what would you still remember even as
space grew dark and empty what meaning
if any would you glean from all of
cosmic history
rust and humus is a world building
project that explores a dreamlike
universe from the cosmic dawn to life at
the end of time created by the visionary
artist and writer lucas rouselle and
translated by laura remy it is perhaps
the most surreal exercise in world
building i've ever encountered
over the course of the project's
123 pages long forgotten gods create
life on barren worlds mortals build
cosmic horrors beyond comprehension and
whales born from dreams visit magician
butterflies on the moon yet in exploring
this strange narrative a profound
meditation on the weight of time in the
cyclical nature of history emerges
so for this entry into the archive i'll
present rust and humus from start to end
and since nothing can prepare you for
what lies within i feel we should just
get started
at the dawn of time an immense tree
dances silently to the rhythm of the
cosmic winds its roots begin in the dark
oceans that cover a planet called earth
though not the earth we know and its
trunk stretches up to the vastness of
space fed by the light and warmth of the
sun the branches of the trees shine in
the infinite darkness for an age longer
than you or i could fathom
until after eons the tree collapses
under its own weight its skeleton
becoming a second satellite orbiting the
earth alongside the moon the tree leaves
behind its base which forms the only
terrestrial continent in the unwavering
ocean at the time of the tree space is
populated with cosmic wanderers who roam
from planet to planet described as
vestiges of forgotten civilizations or
long-lost gods these mysterious beings
can manipulate dream magic to kindle
anew the flames of old stars sculpt the
oceans and give rise to the wind when
the tree breaks the moon is a deserted
satellite of pebbles and stones there
the cosmic wanderers bored and brimming
with power set out to build an orchard
using dreams they create wide seas and
lush vegetation filling the air with the
fragrance of flowers and sweet fruits by
the time these wanderers depart the moon
is a garden where vegetation rapidly
grows wild
the wanderers leave behind a guardian
the oracle weary of observing the silent
stars and growth of plants the
oracle-trained stones had a move
according to the course of the sun and
teaches dust the secret of reason for
eons the oracle and their creations are
the only intelligent life on this green
moon yet time pushes ever forward in
several species that had been evolving
since the selenic waters first flowed
establish coastal cities and occupy the
scattered isles of the moon
the humanoid a lead a seafaring people
with bronze age analogues build one of
the first civilizations in this age of
the dawn using great ships the elite
explore as they spread to the far
reaches of the moon
at this time sea life like the great
cilla alongside the smaller yellow squid
and swimming seaweed provide food for
many civilizations
the
like folk are the era's other largest
society conducting commerce in their
dirigibles and building marbled cities
that proudly soar high into the sky a
group of astronomers and explorers they
chart the stars and trade with the elite
for generations the moon prospers and
civilizations grow and thrive in
relative peace
but this age of tranquility doesn't last
abruptly the sun cools down and the
lunar climate becomes colder and less
predictable in this era of uncertainty
beings known as shapeshifters come down
from the mountains to take advantage of
the ongoing agitation made of dust the
shapeshifters can take the form of
whatever they may choose with their
ability to change shape they infiltrate
the isle's inhabitants taking on the
form of livestock or trusted advisors
they manipulate and curse to settle
their individual quarrels and satisfy
their appetites and so an age of
suspicion and distrust begins
during this period from beyond the sea
dragons beings made of metal and fire
invade the isles to flee the cold
weather and raise countless cities in
their blind hate
in the face of so many catastrophes
civilizations crumble one after another
leaving behind nothing but ruins
the green moon turns white covered in
snow and shrouded in perpetual silence
no cities remain on the moon the few
lifeforms who still wander its
perpetually snow-covered surface are the
moths beings who document things of the
past created by the now elderly oracle
the moths are faithful historians and
scribes immortalizing the civilizations
that rose and fell upon the moon's
surface although there are none left but
themselves to read them
and thus the tale of the moon comes to a
close on a note of quiet lingering
melancholy
yet as the final shroud of snow covers
the moon in the black ocean of earth
life is just beginning a host of
primordial archaeo animals lurk among
the reef achieving a menagerie of
strange forms and growing steadily
larger from these humble roots a story
will play out upon the face of the earth
on a scale that will far exceed the
drama of the moon in the blink of a
cosmic eye the archaeo animals have
given rise to great and terrible
leviathans like the monsters that lurk
in the corners of archaic maps these
aggressive lifeforms clash in constant
battles for dominance yet among these
mindless brutes the intelligent and
deeply social titans have emerged made
of identical clones the titans share a
unified mind and collectively dream of
leaving the somber depths of the ocean
but find themselves unable to do so
gathering together from their collective
dreamscape the titans are able to give
shape to the giants beings endowed with
the ability to carry out the titans
dreams in their stead the first giants
are great whales fated to explore the
sky the second are starry giants who
will roam the planet's surface finally
the black gout lulls stride over the
gloomy oceanic floor taking the place of
the titans and the depths for the titans
are not long for this world
exhausted by their great task after
birthing the giants from their shared
dream the titans finally rest
but the giants fulfill the dream of
their creators with the starry giants
emerging from the sea and venturing onto
the continent formed by the tree long
ago and the great whales exploring the
sky soaring through the heavens like a
flock of great birds finding the land
all but barren they decide to use their
power to transmute the few plants and
dying bugs into vast forests inhabited
by enormous insects largest among these
are the greater earthworms who help
bring fertility to the primordial forest
once their work is accomplished the
giants blend with the forest settling
among the roots allowing their bodies to
dissolve into the vegetation
within these forests the giant insects
reach new levels of size and complexity
despite the abundance of their newfound
environment these insects continue to
engage in the same daily clashes and
squabbles they did when they were
minuscule creatures yet at the end of
each ferocious battle the clamor of
crushed chitin gives way to tiny plants
that will grow into large trees
one peaceful group of insects
butterflies known as the maage will gain
a higher intelligence and learn the ways
of magic using their power they will
leave earth and traverse the universe
some will eventually stop upon the moon
visiting the ancient snow-covered ruins
and interacting with great whales who
flew too high during their egress from
the oceans
back on earth as the forest spreads a
new type of vegetation appears in order
to spread seeds more effectively some
plants acquire mobility some of these
plant animals take on predatory
behaviors hunting for insects in the
underbrush and perhaps even more
noteworthy in other parts of the forest
true animals have emerged in the form of
early proto-mammals the descendants of
the fish that left the dark waters to
take advantage of the newly abundant
food supply of the forest these
miscellaneous wild beasts will grow to
populate all corners of the continent
the sole continent on this planet is
already a land with a long and
mind-bending history yet the story of
this land now called uhiya is about to
become far stranger as eons pass
intelligent reptiles come to unexpected
prominence building hamlets in the
shelter of the woods and opposing the
reptiles are the birds a group of avian
lifeforms who have founded their own
sparse civilization on the continent of
uhiya yet the rise and reign of these
two nations are ultimately just a
footnote in the history of the world for
soon temperatures drop across the
continent and the age of bird and
reptile ends before it can truly begin
in the place of the birds and reptiles
an unlikely two-legged lichen species
called the ancients take up the torch of
civilization
spreading over the continent they form a
society boasting roads and prospering
cities
skilled horticulturalist mechanics the
ancients create living floral structures
and other plant machines to serve as
laborers thanks to their vegetal
workforce the ancient civilization
advances at a rapid pace
as technology improves the largest plant
machines are capable of harnessing
incredible cosmic power fabrication
machines able to bring to materiality
things from the beyond become
commonplace and in time the ancients use
these machines to create something
wholly unexpected humans created by the
fabricator machines as a new workforce
enter the story at last hatched from
mechanical eggs they live and die by the
wills of their creators yet as the
ancient civilization reaches its peak
the human population revolts the ensuing
war is long and terrible remembered in
ancient glyphs and tablets despite their
greater strength and better tools the
ancients non-violent by nature failed to
react quickly enough to stop the human
rebellion in the inferno of war the
ancient civilization is all but erased
humans survive the extinction of the
ancients with great difficulty with
civilization reset once more to a low
level of technological advancement for
centuries the humans live in small
nomadic tribes enduring famine and
sickness
in time a city known as the heart
becomes the center of human civilization
here a group of humans rediscover the
ancients fabrication machines and craft
new versions these new machines the auto
fabs prove even more efficient at
creating things out of the emptiness
than the previous ones thanks to this
miracle from the heart spreads forth the
labyrinth an immense self-built city
where humanity comes to find refuge and
so the age of night terrors and legends
gives way to monolithic cities the
labyrinth continues to spread a maze of
concrete and veins teeming with humans
who find their every need met running at
the human service the city never stops
producing more and more food to fill
plates energy to power devices and
objects to amuse people in their homes
the inhabitants risen to consume from
birth to death
never cease wanting more
within the city wild animals are a
rarity their appearance and customs have
evolved since the emergence of the
labyrinth becoming little more than
pests scurrying at the feet of humanity
and serving the humans are a mosaic of
machines built by the auto fabs to meet
their varied needs in a bitterly ironic
cycle the humans have created their own
underclass just like how the ancients
created them for the same intended
purpose
greatest of all the machines are the
auto fabs themselves partially organic
these living engines continue the
endless work of creating matter from the
emptiness and are kept under close
supervision
and the auto fabs are showing signs of
distress
outgrown buildings containing disfigured
corridors and melted staircases are
becoming increasingly common made of
living tissue these early deviations are
dismissed as anomalies yet other shapes
are forming in the labyrinth anguished
faces appear in the walls and shambling
human-like shapes stumble from the
concrete a catastrophic shift is coming
the autofabs develop a mysterious
sickness in strip districts of power and
food the machines likewise cease
functioning one after another chaos
breaks out across the city as the
labyrinth begins to consume itself the
machine's scream of agony known as the
cry sweeps across the city causing walls
to fall apart in districts to crumble
human civilization has come to an end
the ashes of the city rain down for
years the labyrinth becomes a cemetery
of concrete yet over the coming
centuries after the cry life creeps back
into the silent shell of the city small
groups of human survivors live separated
scraping together a living in darkness
harvesting mushrooms that proliferate
among the ruins
much of the continent of uhiya is now a
polluted desert waste a world of
desolation in ruin
the remainders of humanity reduced once
more to a pre-industrial society come to
congregate in settlements in the
southwestern region of the ruins soon
the age of the machine seems like little
more than fantasy
away from the humans a few populations
of robots still function most free from
their old programming after the cry rang
with breakdowns impossible to repair
rust has become their enemy
the cry also gave rise to odd
occurrences deep within the labyrinth
some districts seem to move and even
seasoned explorers may lose sight of
their path in the ever-changing maze
strangest of all the humans do not dwell
alone in these ruins in their torment
the machine's cry has warped space in
the surrounding matter making way for
the appearances of novel life-forms
which make their home in the labyrinth
the humans consider these unfamiliar
beings monsters and learn to fear the
depths of the maze yet many of these new
forms of life are in fact quite peaceful
despite their surreal and threatening
appearances
along the margins of the inner sea
buildings submerged by the waves sink
into the salt water novel populations
like the whale people make their home on
the grey coasts enjoying the iodine
breeze in available housing
in time the great gout lulls hidden
under the wave since the titans era
surface from the depths to explore the
maze small groups move into buildings
and sift through the ruins of humanity
driven by natural curiosity
eventually the era of the labyrinth also
comes to an end mysterious black trees
begin to pierce through the ruins when
these trees come to maturity they die
and discharge a rich soil or humus that
corrodes the buildings and allows plants
to take root once more once a sufficient
number of black trees die the labyrinth
gives way to a vast forest the forest
gradually engulfs the continent and all
creatures who fail to adapt disappear
no humans remain by this point and the
monsters of the maze begin new lives
treading the green corridors of the
forest underneath the canopy they live
carefully so not to incur the silent
wrath of the trees
for this forest simply called the humus
is actually a single being
interconnected by a web of roots all
trees and plants of the humus are
governed by a single intelligence within
the never-ending forest one can only
hear the whispers of the furtive
assemblies held by birds and tiny
rodents the scars of the labyrinth and
the cry fade away becoming less than a
memory and for another eternity a garden
blooms not seen since the first days of
the moon
yet as we hurtle towards the end of time
this paradise cannot endure eventually
the humus slowly dissolves the trees
whitening before dissipating into dust
once the last grove vanishes a desert
covers the world
the desert left by the humus is breached
with temporal rifts out of which steps
strange roaming beings from the
birthplace of dreams in this place time
has crystallized forming shapes that
echo and joyously prance in the air
abstract beings like living lines and
the time-altering ones flicker in and
out of existence for time is no longer
grounded by the roots of the trees and
in the shifting realm of dreams nothing
can exist for more than a brief moment
get the humus sensing their time was
coming has left their mark in this
desert their egg carefully wrapped in a
cocoon of moss and lichen hatches into a
shapeless being here at the end of time
beyond rust and humus the being sits and
contemplates the void
for how long do they stay there alone
surrounded by only the time wanderers
and the few abstract beings that
occasionally flicker into existence
we cannot say
for such things are not for us to know
in some respects rust and humus is a
story where everything eventually
disappears dies or is forgotten but like
a tool turning to rust or dead leaves
becoming humus after the end of one
system a new one emerges
equal parts melancholy and hopeful the
saga offers many other moments i wasn't
able to cover and you can read the
entire story from start to end using the
links in the description if you found
this narrative as fascinating as i did i
encourage you to follow and support
lucas russell who is working on a
massive follow-up to the project that
will reveal more of this incredible
universe
once again links are down below
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
you